[Musique]
où en est-on de ce vieux rêve de
l'humanité de la fontaine de jouvence
que finalement lucas cranach représenté
comme cette source
où il suffisait de se baigner ou d'en
boire pour voir disparaître à la fois
les maladies où le vieillissement tance
de leon ce navigateur espagnol n'a pas
trouvé bien sûr la fontaine de jouvence
mais uniquement il a découvert une
partie de l'amérique la floride
alors finalement que son d'aujourd'hui
ces aventuriers des temps modernes est
ce que les scientifiques ne le sont pas
devenus est ce que les recherches sur le
vieillissement aujourd'hui nous
permettent d'envisager cette fontaine de
jouvence et est-ce que où en sommes nous
et bien lorsqu'on s'intéresse au
vieillissement
finalement pourquoi s'intéresser au
vieillissement les choses sont il met
peut-être inéluctable eh bien peut-être
parce que eh bien lorsque vous
vieillissez et bien c'est aussi parce
que votre famille et que peut-être
eh bien ça pourrait éviter ce genre de
situation non bien sûr je plaisante mais
peut-être messieurs mais sur les seniors
peut-être qu'il n'est pas trop tard et
que avec un petit peu de sport si vous
suivez l'exemple de cette personne vous
pouvez peut-être retrouver votre
musculature de jeunes hommes ce qui
suggérerait que finalement ce
vieillissement n'est peut-être pas aussi
inéluctable qu'on pourrait le penser
alors ce que l'on sait en tout cas c'est
que l'espérance de vie n'a cessé de
croître ces derniers siècles
elle a doublé au siècle dernier et
aujourd'hui nous gagnons chaque année
trois mois d'espérance de vie
alors bien sûr même si certains nombres
d'épidémiologistes nous dit que
peut-être eh bien nous avons atteint
l'âge limite
toute la question est tout de même de
savoir si cette courbe va s'infléchir ou
bien si nous allons continuer à
progresser de la sorte
si c'est le cas et bien nous pouvons
espérer en 2050 avoir une espérance de
vie tous d'environ 120 ans alors
aujourd'hui chez les femmes elle est de
85 ans et chez les hommes 79
que nous disent les biologistes que nous
disent les chercheurs et bien vous
comprendrez que lorsqu'on s'intéresse au
vieillissement
eh bien nous utilisons des modèles
animaux dans les laboratoires alors on
utilise par exemple ces petits verres
qui ou sous cette mouche qui en raison
de sa courte sa courte vie et bien nous
permet d'explorer des stratégies sur
l'anti âge ou encore et bien cette
souris qui est un animal commun de
laboratoire qui malgré tout est un
mammifère et qui se rapproche de l'homme
alors c'est avec ce petit vert que dans
les années 90 sur la côte ouest des
états unis
cynthia kenyon a identifié qu'il
existait des gènes du vieillissement et
que si on inactive et sgen et bien on
pouvait augmenter la longévité de cet
animal et en combinant l'inactivation de
plusieurs de ses gènes et bien
aujourd'hui on est capable d'augmenter
huit fois la longévité de cet animal est
en bonne santé
j'ai la mouche une stratégie similaire
permet d'augmenter quatre fois la
longévité de cet animal alors bien sûr
pour essayer de comprendre le
vieillissement on ne fait pas que ce que
ça on essaie par exemple de comparer des
espèces avec des longévités différentes
et c'est le cas par exemple
pour ce râteau qui vivent une trentaine
d'années alors que le rat commun lui une
vie que trois ans quels sont les gènes
qui sont impliqués quelles sont les
différences tout ça anime les chercheurs
les chercheurs et puis parfois dans une
même espèce et bien on peut avoir de
grosses différences de longévité
c'est le cas pour la béquille pour une
ouvrière et bien la durée de vie de
quelques mois alors que pour la reine
bien elle est de 5 ans la seule
différence alors que ces animaux au
départ sont des clones est bien c'est
que elle a un mode de vie différent
l'ouvrière travail alors que la reine se
repose et elle garde tout au long de sa
vie une capacité de fécondité que n'a
plus le napa l'ouvrière la seule
différence est là réellement
l'alimentation alors chez l'homme nous
vieillissons aussi à des vitesses
différentes
c'est en corse est particulièrement
dramatique pour ces individus qui sont
atteints de pathologies de
vieillissement précoce puisque ils sont
susceptibles de récapituler toutes les
étapes du vieillissement en quelques
années et mourir de vieillesse à 13 ans
ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui c'est que le
vieillissement la part des jeunes dans
notre longévité et bien et qu'à peu près
de 25 % le reste les 75 autres pour cent
eh bien ça correspond à notre mode de
vie notre alimentation
no stress et c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle puisque probablement sur ça on
peut agir
alors pourquoi nous vieillissons
finalement pourquoi nos organes
vieillissent pourquoi nos tissus
vieillissent et bien c'est par au départ
nos cellules vieillissent
tout au long de notre vie nos cellules
sont soumises à de nombreux stress qui
sont susceptibles de les endommager la
cellule à des mécanismes possibles pour
réparer
c'est endommagement par contre lorsque
les stress sont trop violents eh bien la
cellule peut décider de se détruire
c'est la mort cellulaire et là on voit
diminuer le nombre de cellules dans nos
tissus lorsqu'elle peut réparer c'est
dommage
eh bien elle garde quand même un certain
nombre de traces et elle perd petit à
petit sa capacité à régénérer noter si
la cellule vieillit on dit qu'elle se
déprogramme ou encore et là ça devient
beaucoup plus dramatique c'est lorsque
la cellule ne peut plus se détruire et
qu'elle devient sénescentes qu'est ce
que ça veut dire sept cellules
sénescentes et bien elle arrête de se
diviser
et puis malheureusement elle se met à
synthétiser tout un ensemble de facteurs
dans l'environnement de notre tissu qui
sont susceptibles de désorganiser de
faire vieillir nos tissus qu'on sait
maintenant c'est que eh bien ces
cellules elles s'accumulent ces cellules
sénescentes elles s'accumulent avec
l'âge en grande partie de nos tissus et
elles sont souvent associés à des
pathologies qui sont liées à l'âge aussi
bien l'arthrose l'ostéoporose que la
sarcopénie la fonte musculaire ou encore
la cataracte et bien d'autres alors avec
ce que je viens de vous dire on peut
imaginer et les chercheurs l'ont imaginé
pouvoir avoir un certain nombre
d'interventions pour pallier à ce
vieillissement
on peut éventuellement essayer de
retarder cette sénescence
on peut éventuellement supprimer ces
cellules sénescentes si c'est possible
et puis on peut être stimulé ces
vieilles cellules qui ne sont pas
capables de qui ne sont plus capables de
régénérer nos tissus ou encore essayé
éventuellement de les reprogrammer
puisqu'elles sont déprogrammés alors
aujourd'hui peut-être parmi vous il y à
des personnes qui ont eu une
prescription par exemple pour le diabète
de type 2
un lorsqu'on est atteint de cette
pathologie
eh bien on donne de la metformine la
metformine c'est une molécule qui peut
retarder le vieillissement et surtout
qui va retarder la sénescence
lorsqu'on a par exemple du cholestérol
on va prendre des statines ce sont déjà
des petites molécules des médicaments et
qui vont aussi avoir un effet positif et
retarder la sénescence donc finalement
déjà vous prenez un certain nombre de
médicaments pour traiter vos pathologies
liées à l'âge si vous en avez et 5 sans
le savoir alors retarder la sénescence
n'est peut-être pas suffisant peut-être
qu'on peut essayer détruire ces cellules
sénescentes et c'est ce que les
chercheurs ont fait j'utilise maintenant
des petites molécules qui vont réveiller
dans la cellule sénescentes la capacité
à se détruire
on appelle ça des scénes olitique il ya
tout un ensemble de molécules qui
commencent à sortir et qui sont bientôt
en essai clinique et vous voyez la
différence au niveau de ces souris en
fait lorsqu'on traite ces souris avec
ces molécules qui détruisent les
cellules sénescentes et bien ces souris
non plus de pathologies liées à l'âge la
cataracte et décalé non plus de 2 lors
dose de fonte musculaire et en plus
elles vivent 30 % de plus et en bonne
santé donc essayé d'imaginer si l'on
transposait saalum alors peut-être qu'on
peut essayer aussi de stimuler ses
vieilles cellules à régénérer tout de
même tissu et ça a été fait aussi par
des chercheurs en connectant une souris
jeunes et une souris âgées par la
circulation sanguine et ce qu'ils ont
identifié c'est que eh bien c'était
suffisant pour pouvoir améliorer la
régénération musculaire de la souris
âgées mais aussi de restructurer son
coeur qui étaient dilatées par l'âge et
même récupéré la mémoire spatiale qui
était perdu
chez cet animal voyant même des vieilles
cellules du cerveau faire de nouvelles
connexions pour améliorer le
fonctionnement du cerveau alors
aujourd'hui aux états unis en utilisant
du plasma de personnes jeunes et bien un
essai clinique a été lancée pour voir
dans quelle mesure on pouvait avec ce
plasma de cellules jeunes et bien sûr
des personnes de plus de 60 ans
améliorer leur physiologie et faire
qu'ils aient moins de pathologies liées
à l'âge et notamment un essai est prévu
sur la maladie d'alzheimer
alors pour essayer de d'aller plus loin
essayer de voir comment on pouvait on
pourrait régénérer des tissus et bien on
s'inspire parfois de la nature dans la
nature il y a des capacités
exceptionnelles de régénération par
exemple vous la connaissez tous la
salamandre vous lui coupez un membre
voulait couper la queue ça régénère ceux
petits poissons d'aquarium le poisson
zèbre et bien lorsqu'on lui coupent un
tiers du coeur il régénère sucker la
planère lorsque vous la coupe et une
dizaine de morceaux elle va faire dix
planètes des livres et bien elle refait
des individus quand elle en a envie
on sait maintenant que ces animaux ont
gardé les capacités embryonnaires est
pas et par exemple ils ont gardé des
cellules souches dans le cas de la
planère par exemple elles ont gardé des
cellules souches embryonnaires qui sont
capables de refaire tous les tissus mais
à l'état adulte et chez l'hydre eh bien
elle ne les a pas gardé mais elle est
capable de les re fabriqués alors cette
méduse aussi probablement utilisent ces
cellules souches
puisque vous voyez comme dans ce film de
benjamin button
et bien elle a trouvé le moyen
lorsqu'elle a vieilli de non seulement
détruire ces cellules vieillissante et
une fois qu'elle s'est reproduit et
ensuite elle est là simplement conserver
les cellules souches qui sont capables
refabriquer l'individu
elle fait des cycles de façon infinie de
la sorte est probablement bien que cette
méduse est immortel alors chez l'homme
nous avons des cellules souches
embryonnaires
à quelques jours de la vie on peut les
isoler les cultiver elles sont immortels
et elles vont cette capacité
exceptionnelle à refabriquer n'importe
quel type de tissu puisqu'elles vont
fabriquer l'embryon alors bien sûr il
faut retirer ses cellule d'un embryon
éthiquement ce n'est pas satisfaisant
mais depuis quelques années on peut
prélever une cellule d'un individu et
l'a reprogrammé pour la convertir en une
cellule équivalente à celle de souches
embryonnaires avec tout les mêmes avec
toutes les peaux ses potentialités et
donc dans mon laboratoire nous nous
sommes dit que peut-être avec cette
stratégie pour reprogrammer les cellules
nous pourrions reprogrammer des cellules
vieillissante sommes partis de cellules
de centenaires des cellules sénescentes
et c'est ce que nous avons fait nous
avons converti ses cellules en cellules
souches embryonnaires nous leur avons
fait remonter le temps nous avons
passage effacer les marques du
vieillissement et nous avons pu les rues
différencier en cellules diverses
cellules de la peau nous étions partie
de ces lieux là pour aujourd'hui on peut
suivre ces cellules vous voyez c'est
naissante qui ne bouge pas beaucoup qui
sécrètent ces facteurs qui ne sont pas
capables de régénérer les tissus et
lorsqu'on leur programme pour les re
différencie voilà ce qu'elles font à
nouveau elle se divise
rapidement elles sont une physiologie
juvénile elles sont capables de
restaurer la régénération des tissus
alors aujourd'hui on ne part plus
forcément ni celle de la peau on peut le
faire à partir de vos cellules sanguines
et puis on peut les différencier en
autre chose et vous voyez par exemple
dans la boîte on peut former des
cellules cardiaques qui bat alors ça
ouvre des portes
incroyable des opportunités en médecine
incroyable et bien sûr aujourd'hui on
peut et la science est là pour le faire
utiliser ces cellules comme des
médicaments les injecter faire de la
thérapie cellulaire pour corriger par
exemple un infarctus liée à l'âge on
peut aussi les utiliser pour recoloniser
un coeur avec des vieilles cellules sur
lesquels on aurait supprimé ces cellules
ça se passe aujourd'hui dans les
laboratoires et ont reformé un choeur
fonctionnelle ou encore utiliser des
animaux ça a déjà commencé pour faire se
développer un coeur humain que l'on
pourra ensuite se greffer
alors après cette avalanche de deux
technologies qui permettent soit de
supprimer les seules cellules
sénescentes pour faire que nos tissus
s'améliore et que éventuellement retarde
des pathologies liées à l'âge ou bien
encore reprogrammé nos vieilles cellules
les regrets fait ou même leur fabriquer
des organes et bien vous voyez que la
science a fait beaucoup de progrès sur
le vieillissement et on peut en espérer
beaucoup aujourd'hui
les géants du numérique se sont emparés
de cette quête du graal est par exemple
google est bien à créer une société
calicots qui va injecter 1,5 milliard de
dollars pour tuer la mort facebook mark
zuckerbeg rezzouk en baisse à zuckerberg
pardon et bien 3 milliards de dollars
pour éradiquer l'ensemble des maladies
donc ma conviction c'est que nous sommes
à un tournant de notre histoire et que
probablement le 21ème siècle ne devrait
pas voir cette courbe d'espérance de vie
s'infléchir et pour ceux qui voudraient
aller encore plus loin et bien je ferai
une pirouette pour vous dire que
l'éternité c'est long mais surtout à la
fin je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]